other than a giant bowl lap it up like a
[ __ ] I truly have dreams about a
check-up /hf I'm a recent convert I
think it's like one of the best burgers
out there I'm sorry I'm excited too
oh well that seems easy whoa I love me a
few dozen this is look crashes back look
if you put like a piece of dog [ __ ] on
this bread it's gonna be good
maybe could use some that jack sauce on
a little god I mean who's good like a
bacon lettuce which may don't want a
pickle right yeah I'll bring the [ __ ]
out of that stroke picking it I have on
a try impressive [ __ ] don't keep this
one a secret let it loose
hey this isn't gonna give you the sex
it's not
[Music]
what look at that beautiful
are you joking my ass there's something
you find out of like a food truck at
3:00 a.m. it's like taco burger baby
Harlem to your house and you name you
this I'd be like oh this is very good
drunk food I mean
[Music]
all right I mean there's a lot of judge
here and we don't actually do the
peppers a lot yeah it adds a new
dimension to the creaminess it's almost
like a mix between a cheese sauce and I
can operate or thought this is something
wrong that you want watching a sporting
event here's the thing shake shake fries
are so good not ever needs to have bacon
oh I would eat this for forever until
it's taken away from me really
[Music]
a burger right whoa okay now we're
[ __ ] up how are the weirds he what is
he doing there
I'm so excited for this because my
secret ingredient in smoothies is peanut
butter that's not a secret
a lot of people sticking bets in the
mouth she's like a Nutter Butter
this will be the picture on my [ __ ]
food Oh after good though
thanks pretty good it's the best one by
far because it actually has the Shake
Shack burger in it it's like I'm eating
two sandwiches a watch
to me I just like lots of flavor so
since this adds a new layer of
complexity I'm into it I don't even know
they have for some reason it's [ __ ]
delicious maybe a little bit jelly and
less meat what I'm saying is if there's
no butter jelly I'd really like it but
how do you order this though hi I've
lost my damn mind
can I please have some food no one sober
would eat this
[Music]
beer whoa there's beer in it oh let's
get [ __ ] up sure you drinking like
we're on a date sure like you so yeah I
don't think this is all you what it does
make the beer taste better cuz it's got
like a little sweetness it kind of
tastes like iced coffee I feel like I
was on a date I just like fight them
[ __ ] like this can I be those drunk
people there's like I need beer by the I
put some put some ice on that this is
what a butterbeer should be you know
when you go dude whatever here for the
first time you're like oh [ __ ] it's just
soda yeah this is a [ __ ] butter beer
all right shake sack you you let us have
it today I love you why are we keeping
this a secret this should be shouted
from the rooftops I want everyone to
know about this it's like a relationship
just be loyal and if you're interested
in trying new things and offer a
threesome with your partner you are
drunk I'm not drunk I'm just happy